der neue mobilfunkstandard 5g könnte
alle und nicht nur die gegen diesen
nutzen krank machen denn die technologie
wird menschen sehr nahe kommen um
schneller mehr daten an noch mehr
endgeräte zu verteilen doch die
wissenschaft ist sich nicht einig
darüber was 5g mit unserer gesundheit
macht zwei studien haben unabhängig
voneinander beunruhigende ergebnisse und
den usa wurden sogar 200 studien
analysiert fiction die gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
dieses video ist in zusammenarbeit mit
technology review entstanden dem
technologie magazin des emmett dem
massachusetts institute for technology
und am ende gibt es ein exemplar für
euch umsonst also 5g macht es möglich
einen film bis zu 600 mal schneller
laden als mit dem besten dsl anschluss
autos die in echtzeit kommunizieren
ferngesteuerter operationen und
kühlschränke die für uns mit denken die
datenraten bei 5 g liegen bis zu 100 mal
höher als beim aktuellen lte standard
und der ist schon ziemlich schnell
zudem soll es uns eine
reaktionsgeschwindigkeit von nicht
einmal mehr einer millisekunde
ermöglichen und auch die zahl der
verbundenen geräte soll sich gleich für
100 fachen doch welche risiken gehen wir
durch die elektromagnetische strahlung
unserer handys und den dazugehörigen
funkmasten 1 macht 5g uns alle krank
fest steht dass 5g sehr nah an uns
menschen heran rücken wird denn die
reichweite ist gering und deshalb müssen
die funkmasten näher an die menschen
gebracht werden selbst einfache wände
aus beton können die mobilfunkwelt sonst
nicht durchdringen er sind viele
antennen nötig und es entsteht ein netz
mit einer dichte die es so bislang noch
niemals gab kann 5g also möglicherweise
krebs auslösen und schadet es den
männlichen samen fest steht wenn
mobilfunkstrahlen auf gewebe treffen
wird ihre energie absorbiert und das
gewebe erwärmt sich manche fachleute
vermuten dass durch diese erwärmung
moleküle brechen und so krebs entstehen
könnte
darauf gibt es noch keine eindeutigen
hinweise dennoch sollen die sogenannten
sah grenzwerte dafür sorgen dass sich
die menschliche körper temperatur durch
die bestrahlung nicht mehr als ein grad
erhöht und das ist ja dann schon eine
menge denn unumstritten ist
unser herz kreislauf system durch eine
dauerhaft erhöhte körpertemperatur
leidet trotz intensiver forschung kennt
man noch nicht die detaillierten
vorgänge in zellen die ablaufen wenn
mobilfunk quellen auf diese treffen
höchstwahrscheinlich könnte dies aber zu
einer indirekten erbgutverändernde
wirkung führen die folgen davon könnte
krebs sein noch ist das alles
spekulation doch inzwischen gibt es
studien vor allem zwei studien werden
von den fünf g kritikern und
kritikerinnen genannt beide wurden 2008
10 veröffentlicht aber bereits vor 15
jahren also 2005 gestartet unter anderem
im auftrag der us-gesundheitsbehörde fdp
beide studien hatten untersucht wie sich
ein netz von mobilfunkstrahlen auf
ratten und mäuse auswirkt in dem
amerikanischen experiment handelt es
sich um die strahlungsdosis die auch ein
handy in den usa während des
telefonierens abgibt in der anderen
studie aus italien war es eine deutlich
geringere dauer bestrahlung die tiere
waren im feld schon im mutterleib
ausgesetzt die ergebnisse der beiden
untersuchungen stimmten quasi über ein
und das obwohl sie komplett unabhängig
voneinander durchgeführt worden waren
und das zeigt dass ihre ergebnisse mit
hoher wahrscheinlichkeit eben belastbar
und verlässlich sind die tiere hat nach
einer zeit die 55 menschlichen lebens
jahren entspricht hirntumore entwickelt
und zwar nicht irgendwelche sondern
äußerst ungewöhnliche hirntumore zudem
mit kamen die nagetiere geschwulst an
den herz nerven sehr seltene schwan omen
dazu die pathologin fiorella belotti die
an der italienischen studie beteiligt
war
als ich diese daten sah wusste ich
sofort wir haben hier ein echtes problem
eine bestimmte häufung in einer studie
kann immer zufall sein aber wenn sich
seltene tumore in zwei unabhängig
laufenden studien helfen dann ist das
nicht mehr mit zufall zu erklären denn
beide tumorerkrankungen hängen
biologisch gesehen zusammen sie
betreffen das bindegewebe dass die
nervenzellen voneinander isoliert die
italienische wissenschaftlerin
appelliert jetzt an die politik in
sachen 5g umzudenken und vorsichtig zu
sein
zudem hat sie in italien eine petition
gegen den 5 g ausbau gestartet auch
andere vorschnell haben bedenken und 300
fachleute haben eine petition an die eu
geschrieben und wollen somit den ausbau
verhindern
doch auf der anderen seite ist auch klar
dass sich die beiden tier laborversuchen
nicht eins zu eins auf menschen
übertragen lassen denn die wellenlängen
des 5 gegen netze sind deutlich kürzer
als die des damals üblich
netzes das auch schon dichter an den
menschen rücken musste als die d netze
strahlen fachleute sind der ansicht dass
das von vorteil ist denn je kürzer die
wellen sind umso leichter lassen sie
sich ablenken zudem ist auch ihre
eindringtiefe geringer zudem sind
menschen bedingt durch ihrem
wasseranteil leitend und die verwendeten
elektromagnetischen strahlen lassen sich
leicht von leitenden materialien
ablenken
außerdem sind die körpergrößen und auch
vor allem die volumen von menschen und
ratten enorm verschieden und auch
deswegen lassen sich die experimente
nicht ganz so einfach von tier auf
mensch übertragen die mobilfunk quellen
dringen nur einige zentimeter in das
gewebe ein und so können sie zumindest
bei erwachsenen das herz überhaupt nicht
erreichen aber aufgepasst denn die
menschliche großhirnrinde beispielsweise
liegt nur einige wenige zentimeter tief
und könnte somit also von den mobilfunk
quellen erreicht werden und tatsächlich
dass solche krebsregister sieht eine
leichte zunahme bei den hirntumoren
bislang schiebt man das jedoch auf eine
verbesserte diagnostik das bundesamt für
strahlenschutz bfs jedenfalls geht nicht
davon aus dass 5g gesundheitlichen
schaden verursacht denn bestätigte
anhaltspunkt auf mögliche effekte fehlen
demnach können die radiowellen die
menschliche dna nicht unmittelbar
schädigen auch eine indirekte schädigung
beispielsweise durch freie radikale
konnte bislang nicht bewiesen werden
auf der anderen seite gibt es aber auch
keine beweise dafür dass
mobilfunkstrahlen völlig unschädlich
sind das sagt auch das bundesamt für
strahlenschutz das in sachen 5g bislang
nur die aufgabe hat aktuell studien zu
bewerten eigene forschungen des neu
gegründeten kompetenzzentrum
elektromagnetische felder sollen sich
vor allem auf magnetische felder beim
ausbau des stromnetzes konzentrieren die
ergebnisse der italienischen analyse
schiebt das bfs auf eine zu hohe
exposition der ratten also sie sind zu
stark belastet worden demnach würden
sich menschen in einem normalen handy
netze niemals so stark erwärmt da sie ja
deutlich größer sein da war das hat mir
schon die tumore die sich bei den tieren
entwickelt hatten könnten demnach auch
eine folge eine direkte folge der
temperaturerhöhung sein
zudem sei die italienische untersuchung
auch nicht abgeschlossen denn bislang
wurden nur die herzen und gehirne der
tiere analyse schlüssig ist diese
argumentation also nicht ganz denn
schließlich gibt es auch keine studien
darüber dass es in wärmeren klimazonen
zu hören
krebsraten kommt warum also sollte es
wahrscheinlich sein dass die tumore
durch die krebs auslösende wirkung von
wärme entstanden sind als durch die
strahlen wirkung selbst die
us-amerikanische gesundheitsbehörde fdp
dagegen hat 125 tierversuche und 75
menschen versuchen überprüft demnach
gebe es zitat kein einheitliches muster
um hochfrequente strahlung mit tumoren
oder krebs in verbindung zu bringen
dennoch gibt es auch von dieser seite
aus den dringenden appell diese
möglicherweise heiklen thema in weiteren
studien nachzugehen und jetzt gibt es
ein geschenk für euch in zusammenarbeit
mit der redaktion von technology review
ist dieses video entstanden nun exklusiv
für klicks umzuschauen de gibt es jetzt
eine ausgabe gratis gibt dafür einfach
auf diesen link her oder unten in der
video beschreibung also auch
funktioniert es lohnt sich
technology review ist mega interessant
und hier geht es zu einem weiteren video
das wir mit der redaktion zusammen
gemacht haben ewiges leben möglich klick
drauf wenn es euch interessiert
abonniert uns und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran